I will eat an entire tray of brownies
and then happily feel like garbage
laughter yeah that's fine with the best
box brownies I think I already know
brownies I do remember like I can have
some vivid memories pop up of like my
mom making the brownies like the whole
put the fork or the toothpick in you
know to like see if it's done
I like gooey soft brownies that are a
little bit crispy on the outside I don't
like hard brownies Lee I've seen
brownies that are like they're not
brownies they're these are biscuits
brands though I feel like that is well I
could get saved I think a Betty Crocker
as a brand isn't it that's like the
classic mom brand I feel like I feel
like Betty Crocker is like your mom
swears by it and she always gets that
but here's the real team
it is Ghirardelli it's like Valentine's
Day you get the gear Adelie you know he
really is the best brownie there is no
question about it I have tested multiple
I have an actual problem all right it's
lucky pretty gooeys was the centerpiece
I believe this looks to be pretty fudgy
it looks moist in the middle and I like
that there's like a almost like a
crunchy like layer the best brownies
required this top layer the crunch and
the gooeyness of the batter
all right okay you got him do something
mm-hmm well I like it soft but this one
might be too soft I got the edge piece
so I'm rocking it with the softness
phenomena mm-hmm I don't understand how
the other ones aren't gonna taste is
like this one I'm trying to channel my
Great British Bake Off I'm like
impression stocky bottom soggy about it
but it looks like it needs to be proven
a little bit more we need air pockets
but the flavor flavor is exquisite
that's not a British accent the only
criticism I would give them is I want to
be punched in the face with chocolate
like I want to feel it tomorrow the best
part of a brownie is that just crystal
thin little layer whatever it's like
translucent and crispy on top two
different words o best of a boat okay
[Music]
the colors a lot lighter on the top it's
looking a lot different um maybe that
means it's more like a milk chocolate
and the other one is more like a dark
chocolate or something like that one is
like almost peanut butter yeah that's
what I was thinking
caramel yeah you need Carly already you
know I like the the texture of this one
a little bit better it's this is gonna
sound weird but I like the flavor of the
darker chocolate one mm-hmm but the
texture of this one is really doing it
for me
not my favorite there's feels more like
a muffin to me ha ha ha you know what I
think that's what I'm lagging about it
more important is texture wise is a
little different I prefer the first one
mm-hmm
just like borderline too moist but yeah
this box was picked on the left side of
the Costco in the early summer day like
on a brownie points-- level the last one
was much higher up on a chocolaty factor
this one's an even lower chocolaty
factor to me it was aged on the Shelf
approximately 5 months the consistency I
don't like as much as the first and the
flavor is not as strong it's not quite
as sweet I was not as brownie ish okay
just have them all the chocolate kind of
gluey
there's a difficult and there's brownie
like am I gonna eat it all probably but
like I'm not happy
[Music]
see the name of the corner piece here
this one definitely has the consistency
after like what anymore you think it
looks crumbly
it looks gooey as this would look a lot
more similar to the first one than the
last one did what is more brownie yeah
absolutely
yeah this takes more like a brownie like
is this here's a brownie brownie I will
save this to me so it's a little kinky
yeah this is so good there is a
wonderful chocolate taste going on in
here
this is more what I mean where it's like
hmm not quite as like dense and like
gooey and fudgy okay so very moist it's
good yeah I'm not mad at it it's like
right on the board a lot dude it like
literally melted in my mouth but like it
melted as like a sugar clump it's just
like a clump
a little bit of a crust and a very
present chocolate paper this is a new
top contender upon first impressions I'm
excited to me it has everything that I
have been wanting it's a combination of
the first two which I thoroughly enjoyed
see now a little fuzzier look at that
see I'm just kind of like okay okay
I regret making that noise yeah this one
already feels a little more compact to
me condense I'm gonna clear my palate by
drinking more milk
this is mama can you see the difference
texture-wise so this is more like mushy
is the wrong word texture wise I think
it's too soft that hasn't been same
amount of time yeah I'll handle it
this is a decadent brownie mm-hmm
splendiferous one obvious my luck we may
have found at you guys oh you found the
one
Wow I only have a little milk alive
we've gotta make this go it's got a
weird like topping there's not really
that like crust that you normally expect
I'll have like a brownie
we'd like crumbles more I'm already
think I'm gluten for you of course yeah
this oh okay well here's here's my issue
with this one
and I think you're right I think it's
gonna be a gluten-free because I touched
this and I crumbled into six pieces I do
see something but it does look a lot
less gooey than the others did mm-hmm
it tastes like it's trying to be gluten
or three or something is it just like
flour it's only flour it might be like
either gluten-free or something because
it's like powdery my favorite brownie is
one because it tastes like the classic
brownie that I grew up with I agree I
like one it's not too sweet
and I like the texture yeah I got
excited over one a little bit ago nobody
I think that was the second one we drew
I think that was one of the most excited
for I think that was a price I think
number one did it for me
you know I wasn't looking for too much
more they gave me the brownie flavor
it was moist it was wonderful I believe
that number four is my favorite I think
there's just more of that chocolate
taste in four three had a little bit
less to me I think so I think four is
gonna be my number one I agree with you
that one was like quintessential brownie
love it but we all have our own little
brownie preferences so for me number
four was like kind of just like one but
a little gooey oh yeah and like that
just that's Betty Crocker yes there was
a reason why that's the only name I have
that's wild you guessed it right off the
bat a man who knows what I like well
there you go
no wonder that Sony billion people are
like I don't like sugar or anything if
you know it's gluten-free then you have
a hope or expectation of taste and so
you forgive it for not tasting like so
here's the thing he says number one I
say number four and we're both right you
feel me
get what your friends need make two
batches in brown